mais
à peine 20 minutes de bateau pour
parvenir à l'île d'aix
lee en vélo
ici pas besoin de pistes cyclables sur
les trois petits kilomètres de terre en
forme de croissant
les voitures sont tous interdits
tout le monde se déplace en vélo on
récupère les vélos des grands-parents
des arrière grands parents ont les
retape on les repeints on les reprend
les raffy sol a plus le vélo les vieux
plat de la valeur à l'île d'aix
le problème c'est peut-être et fait rage
et les freins c'est parfois un peu
risqué donc francs avant droit est un
petit peu bizarre et je ne suis pas le
seul sur l'île d'aix temps en temps
quelques atterrissages disgracieux
chaque jour trois voire 400 bicyclettes
trouve locataires pour une cinquantaine
de fou avec un petit supplément quand on
choisit l'option semi remorque
on a connu ça pendant la guerre récente
et quand on est garagiste sur l'île
d'aix
on répare forcément des vélos cet été
laurent est devenu expert en câbles de
freins l'île d'aix 150 habitants en
hiver
quinze mille vélos l'été
une quinzaine de kilomètres de routes et
de chemins permettent de découvrir un
environnement épargné par le béton et
les gaz d'échappement jusqu'au fond de
la rade
c'est loin ça fait km 2 km alors on
s'habitue à pédaler attention on voit en
surcharge
un clin d'oeil du fort boyard une
sonnette virulente
on n'a plus vraiment envie de quitter
l'île d'aix